meanwhile nancy pelosi um was was on
hillary clinton's podcast and i
i just learned that hillary hillary
clinton has a podcast apparently
i don't know who would sit down and
listen to a hillary clinton
podcast of all things but i guess some
people do at least nancy pelosi does and
she was on the the podcast uh talking
about
many things but really focusing on the
trauma
that uh people in congress suffered on
january 6 during the rides let's listen
to that
i as an american am incredibly grateful
for your steadiness
and your devotion to our democracy
how are you holding up well first let me
just say i was very much
looking forward uh to being with you uh
the
kind words that you say i accept on
behalf of my house democratic caucus
colleagues
they've been so courageous so steadfast
so patriotic so committed
to their oath of office and they said at
that point
that there were storming the capital and
the security just
whisked away but it was stunning
but i know again they are protective and
i thought well
okay yeah i'll go with you because it's
your job to make sure that i do
and i don't want to endanger anybody
else and i'm a target
you know so so when we got in the car
i said well where are we going like to
another room
no we're going to an undisclosed
location
you know when i hear um talk of the the
trauma
and they haven't stopped talking about
how traumatic it was for them this whole
experience
but whenever i hear this my mind i go
back to a story that
i don't you may have forgotten about or
you may not have heard at all because it
wasn't exactly something that the
mainstream media was eager to report but
just one example you know you go back to
the riots throughout the summer and
um so many just just just you have your
pick of the litter you pick so many
examples of traumatic
things that uh that regular american
citizens suffered
and people like nancy pelosi never said
a word about that never spoke a word
about the trauma
of people who live in these cities that
have been racked by by rioting
uh the businesses burned down family
members killed
you know i i don't know the family
members of david dorn for example
nancy pelosi ever say anything about
that the trauma they're suffering
but i go my mind goes back to one
particular incident
um the chicago ronald mcdonald house
cancer center for children during the
rioting in chicago
which there was riding all throughout
the summer right uh during the blm
rioting
the cancer center was attacked
by rioters okay yes they attacked a
cancer center for children
and there were kids inside their
families inside and they were terrified
because they're listening to the windows
being smashed
downstairs now just imagine that for a
second i mean imagine you're a child and
you're sick with cancer and you're
and and then you hear this commotion
outside these these unruly crowds
you hear the windows being smashed in
your building imagine you're a parent of
a child
going through that there was one young
child and we talked about this at the
time so maybe if you've been listening
if you've been listening to this show
you heard about this at least um
one young child owen believed was his
name two years old fighting stage four
cancer
and he was supposed to go home to sell
it to his birthday party that day
and he couldn't go home he missed his
birthday party now they celebrated it
later but he missed his birthday party
that day
because of the uh because of the writing
outside it was it was unsafe to leave
the building
so i you know i don't know when i think
about trauma
that people suffered emotional trauma
that they suffered during writing i am
much much more concerned about those
kids
and many other children too affected by
it
but even just that one case
i'm more concerned about their emotional
trauma think about the emotional trauma
they are suffering that's something that
they're going to remember in their
nightmares probably for the rest of
their lives
i i just i'm a lot more concerned about
that than i am about the
the trauma the emotional trauma of grown
adults
powerful people politicians in congress
that's just me i certainly reject the
idea that we're supposed to be
more concerned about that about their
trauma the politicians
and what happened to them was so much
worse
it was it was a desecrating sacred
ground
and sacred people apparently
i i absolutely reject that listen
hit that subscribe button right now do
it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated